bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous une
petite question tout d'abord sur le chef
du gouvernement espagnol pedro sanchez
qui va s'isoler il est lui aussi qu'à
contacter d'emmanuel macron j'ai ce pas
si vous avez eu l'occasion de regarder
les chaînes d'information peut-être
espagnol cet aprem unique comment
réagit-on en espagne ou en tout cas
comment réagit peut-être plus facile
pour vous d'y répondre le médecin que
vous êtes l'un des chefs d'état des
chefs du gouvernement qui se met
peut-être en danger les uns et les
autres
ça vous inspire quoi ils n'ont pas assez
respecté les mesures sanitaires qu'ils
imposent peut-être à leur peuple
bonsoir c'était fini de murs rue alors
évidemment c'est une question que je me
suis posée c'est à dire qu'elle est
qu'elle est effectivement le rôle du
chef de l'état
en termes d'exemplarité dans ce contexte
et je crois que on ne peut pas à la fois
demander à un chef de l'état d'assumer
ses fonctions avec la complexité de la
charge dans une période particulièrement
difficile où probablement la charge de
travail qui incombe au président de la
république est plus importante qu'à
l'ordinaire avec effectivement la
gestion en plus des affaires courantes
et en même temps lui demander
effectivement d'être dans une zone de
zéro risque parce que on imagine bien
que cela se ferait aux dépens de
l'exercice de ses fonctions
donc je ne crois pas qu'on puisse jeter
la pierre à nos dirigeants de contracter
le coc vide parce que finalement ils
sont plutôt courageux il s'expose plus
que nous effectivement au risque compte
tenu des réunions qu'ils doivent tenir
compte tenu des enjeux qu'ils doivent
continuer à assumer et finalement ça
n'est pas étonnant que on apprenne que
nos dirigeants que ce soit effectivement
le premier ministre anglais où que ce
soit aujourd'hui emmanuel macron et bien
que aussi finissent par être contaminé
ça dit aussi que décidément tout le
monde peut se contaminer parce qu'on
imagine que ces chefs d'état très
protégé notamment par des services de
sécurité toute la journée autour d'eux
je parle aussi de donald trump de boris
johnson et vient finalement ils
contractent le virus avec autant de
facilité
est ce que la population ne peut pas
tout simplement se dire que voilà c'est
très compliqué de l'éviter ce virus
qu'on peut l'attraper même si d'une
certaine manière on se protège parce
qu'on imagine bien qu emmanuel macron a
dû forcément être protégés et se
protéger oui vous avez vraiment raison
ce qui caractérise avant tout ce virus
avant sa dangerosité qui est finalement
somme toute quand même encore à un
niveau acceptable c'est sa contagiosité
on a annoncé une contagiosité de trois à
quatre fois supérieur à la grippe mais
c'est exactement ce qu'on constate et
s'il est difficile d'échapper à la
grippe
s'il est parfois facile d'échapper la
grippe il s'avère extrêmement difficile
d'échapper dans le temps
aux commandes un virus l'espagne a
malheureusement la situation s'aggrave
chez vous également parle de ce long
week-end férié qui pourrait en être la
cause
est-ce que la proche des fêtes de
famille vous en tant que médecin vous
inquiète particulièrement non écoutez je
trouve finalement que tout cela
finalement fait perdre un peu la tête
parce que on savait très bien
effectivement que la perspective des
fêtes de noël et des fêtes de fin
d'année entraînerait une hausse à
nouveau des contaminations et
constituerait une zone de l'année à
risque mais on sait aussi que l'année
2005 nous venons de vivre a été
excessivement difficile pour pour la
population et que effectivement
aujourd'hui se dire qu'on va clôturer
l'année comme on l'a vécu c'est à dire
avec un taux de restriction maximum
et bien c'est difficile à accepter c'est
difficile à accepter et donc aujourd'hui
évidemment on voit remonter un petit peu
les taux de contaminations à barcelone
ou à madrid
mais enfin on est quand même kaka 200
quintaux de 200 contamination pour
100000 habitants ce qui est pas non plus
extraordinaire est finalement bon on se
demande
on se demande où est la cohérence dans
tout ça parce que on avait accepté de
relâcher un petit peu la pression
justement pour redonner un petit peu
plus d espace de vie à la population
tout en sachant pertinemment de toute
façon qu'on ne peut pas je dirais
converger vers un risque zéro
or le confinement total et général est
aujourd'hui évidemment ça remonte un peu
mais c'est pas une surprise et
finalement eh ben on trouve comme
solution de dire dans va effectivement
verrouiller les sept
alors il ya aussi vous disiez barcelone
évidemment madrid mais l'île de majorque
était jusqu'ici épargné les maintenant
touchés
la faute justement entre guillemets
c'est à ces touristes et vacanciers
n'ont écouté c'est tout à fait
prévisible parce que ce à quoi on a
assisté à barcelone par exemple c'est
que les gens ont décidé d'aller se
mettre au vert et finalement il y avait
très peu de choix pour par exemple pour
les gens qui habitent à barcelone
c'était soit majorque sur les canaries
est effectivement en moi dans mon
entourage j'ai vu un certain nombre
effectivement d'amis de patients partir
à majorque partir aux canaries et donc
on a eu une espèce d'arrivée de
concentration effectivement de deux
personnes dans 6 il est très logiquement
eh bien ça a nourri effectivement une
aggravation du taux de contamination
aujourd'hui dr emmanuelli la seule issue
finalement c'est le vaccin vous êtes au
petit nice optimiste confiant justement
sur les premières actions avec sa
vaccination pardon je vais y arriver qui
doivent intervenir le 27 décembre en
europe
oui alors écoutez la difficulté c'est
qu'il n'y a pas d' analyse ni noire ni
blanche c'est à dire que d'un côté on a
effectivement cette épidémie qui n'en
finit plus avec en plus des mutations
qui sont annoncés en angleterre depuis
quelques jours qui touche justement la
structure du virus contre lequel le
vaccin doit agir donc d'un côté on sent
bien qu'il y a urgence à agir si on ne
veut pas retomber dans un scénario noir
où couraient après épidémie et puis de
l'autre côté il y à ces vaccins et
notamment ce vaccin arn qui il faut le
dire je me suis penchée sur les textes
scientifiques parce qu'en conscience
comme médecin d'abord je veux savoir si
je vais me vacciner et je veux savoir ce
que je peux conseiller la population en
tout cas en confiance est ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que ce vaccin qui nous
est proposé c'est un pas de géant ça
correspond effectivement
scientifiquement à la conquête de la
lune
on est vraiment sur une prouesse
scientifique absolument incroyable on ne
dit pas assez mais c'est une révolution
mais de l'autre côté et c'est bien pour
ça aujourd'hui qu'il ya une réticence
dans la population
de l'autre côté on fait un pas dans ce
qu'on pourrait appeler le
humanisme c'est à dire un petit peu
cette tendance à faire de l'homme un
super homme qui est en vogue aux états
unis depuis vingt ans et on flirte avec
le transhumanisme parce que vraiment on
flirte avec effectivement la question du
génome chez l'homme même si la rn ne
rentre pas dans la cellule même si
effectivement il disparaît au bout de 15
minutes pour la première fois peut-être
dans l'humanité on va faire fabriquer
par l'homme artificiellement une
molécule étrangères au corps humain
justement c'est quelque chose vous le
décrivez très bien qui est très innovant
qu'on connaît mal le scepticisme est il
aussi fort en espagne qu'en france
quant à la vaccination alors le débat
est moins important en espagne à la
population espagnole est assez pro
vaccin donc c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas le
débat dans la même intensité que que
qu'en france
et puis surtout c'est moins un sujet
médiatique c'est à dire que c'est moins
un sujet de débat même dans les médias
merci à vous philippe emmanuel y
médecins français exerçant à barcelone
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france